I saw this quote on someone's blog the
other day and the title was our stories
made or found it's a fine line between
made or found like what does that really
mean but right is it something that you
see some women walking down the street
and you just envision what their life is
like and you're like I'm gonna write
this or you read an article hear
something on NPR and you say I want to
do a fictionalized version of that all
of the above sometimes an idea will come
to me by seeing a guest on a TV show
talking about something NPR's a great
source of that kind of stuff
my Leanna's always saying to me oh I
heard this this great interview on NPR
you should make a script about that you
know one really interesting one which is
nowadays I just kind of like oh my god
so the of the two scripts that I that I
originally can't show - William Asher
you know he's he's the one he didn't
care for because it had a supernatural
magic element to it right that that was
a sort of a modern version of an old
Chinese story that was a children's book
that I remembered reading when I was a
kid it was called the five Chinese
brothers and in it these these this one
brother gets in trouble with the Emperor
and he's sentenced to death right but
the each one of these brothers has a
power has an interesting power so
they're gonna so they and they all look
alike
right so the so they're gonna say okay
we're gonna throw you into the ocean so
you drown right but the the one brother
has the ability to swallow the entire
ocean so he you know so he doesn't drown
and another one they're gonna feed him
to an alligator or something like that
and the brother has a like a neck that's
like unbreakable and so they keep
switching him out and so that they can't
kill him right and so in around 1990 oh
maybe earlier than that eighty maybe
eighty eight eighty
somewhere around there I'm watching him
home during the day and I'm watching The
Oprah Winfrey Show and Donald Trump was
the guest and at that time they were
making him out to be like he was gonna
be this you know this amazing god-like
person that he thinks he is now and he
but he sounded legitimate like he
sounded like he was a really really
smart guy and he was really good at
things and I remember that Oprah asked
him if he was ever consider running for
office right and he didn't he was king
of a bit kind of a vague answer but I
just remember him saying that like well
I've tell you this that if I do decide
to run for office I'll do it I'll do it
full-on like I won't you know I won't
hold back all right and I thought to
myself what if this guy knows something
that we don't like what if this guy can
see into the future right and then I
started thinking about that Chinese
brothers story right and I thought what
if what if there was these these five
brothers who were had built up this huge
corporation because no one else knew
that each of them had a power and one of
them could if he held your hand he could
read your mind and one of them held your
hand he could see a little bit into your
future another one could hold your hand
and he could heal you of your whatever
your illness is and the other brother
who was a twin if he held your hand he
could kill you
just by touching you and then there was
a fifth brother and the fifth brother
was the one they were grooming to be a
politician right so that was the basis
of this story that that I that was the
other script that I had with return to
gargoyle all right and it was big it was
this is like I said you know everybody's
making a die hard movie back then
because this the spec script what it was
through the roof where they were they
were buying a big high concept scripts
all over the place
so it was a huge movie the whole thing
like it Scott there's a whole skyscraper
on fire and all this kind of stuff right
and but that came from me seeing Donald
Trump on the Oberoi vision and stuff
like that happens all the time
I once witnessed in a courtroom I saw a
guy try to get out of a DUI having to
pay the fines or or you know do
community service or anything like that
and he and he and he said he said to the
judge well I'm a screenwriter
I could I could write a PSA about not
drinking and driving to instead of you
know instead of doing that and and the
judge was like no but I gave the guy
credit for trying you know but I came
that inspired an idea of a script that
I'm working on now right just that
little little moment that I happen to
witness so he never know where it's come
comes from lately I'm now working on the
third adaption of an existing novel that
I've been hired to write so I adapted
the first one was I adapted a novel that
was written by James Franco's mom who's
an she's an author Yeah right and so I
was hired to take her novel and make it
into a movie because you know you can't
you have to make changes in adapting
sometimes change a lot of things and the
one I'm working on now is a murder
mystery that is set in the world of
magicians and that also was an existing
material that was a book that was so
when I was hired or before I was hired
actually my my manager sent me the book
I said read this tell me if you think
you can do something with it and I read
it and I was like I could definitely do
something with it and so and so I was
hired to do that so sometimes those
things are brought
to me and sometimes also you know
there's been many times when I think I
might have said before that I'll be
brought in to a company that has an
existing material I mean so they call it
script doctoring sometimes and they
really want to make this movie they love
the concept but the script they have is
unfilmable so I'll have to come in and
basically usually start from scratch
usually toss the existing material stay
with the concept but make it a movie
that that can be made and make it up
make it a script that can be actually
made into a movie write that that works
as a movie as opposed to you know I I
never even look who you know who the
person is that wrote the earlier draft I
had one oh my god this one this was the
best I was brought in for this to this
one project and they said well we're
gonna send you the script and it's
called beware of elevators right so no
title of the movie is is beware of
elevators what kind of movie do you
think that would be oh well maybe some
people will be stuck in a high-rise
elevator right so like a drama sure you
know maybe a horror movie
right what I was thinking too right
maybe what elevator has a mind of its
own
yeah all right so that's what I'm
expecting I get the script and I start
to read it and I realize about 10 pages
in that this is a movie about a guy who
dies in an elevator and he comes back as
his fiancee's dog and the movie is the
guy trapped in the dog's body and we're
hearing his thoughts and everything as
he's now trying to basically protect his
his fiancee and help her get over the
grief and everything like that right
well it was it was just terrible it was
a terrible script right and I burped I
was gonna pass on it I was gonna say no
I just
they're gonna do a talking dog movie
sorry but then right before then I just
had a thought and I and I thought what
what can i what could how could I
possibly make this work and what I ended
up doing was turning it into a mystery
because in the original script you you
you you find out how the guy dies right
away right then some that's he died in
an elevator right so what I did was have
the the I comes back as a dog doesn't
doesn't remember why how he died and so
over the course of the the script he
started he little by little he starts
getting flashes of what happened that
night and the further along the more
flashes he gets he more he starts to put
it together as to what happened and so
it became more than just a comedy about
a guy trapped in a dog's body it also
became sort of a mystery because we're
finding out it's unfolding you know it's
like peeling an onion you're finding out
little by little what led to that and
how and why did he end up here in this
dog's body and then it worked
and III into I am too loving that script
it's like what I really loved you'll
probably never get made but you know
that's that's how it goes I mean I still
got paid now you know that's so funny
that's a that's a big misconception also
about screenwriters okay people a lot of
people think that working screenwriters
what we do we write a script and then it
gets made and then we go in the next
script and it gets made and we're in the
next River you get made I would say 5%
of the scripts that I get hired to write
get made 5% but I'm still a working
screen right you get hired you write a
script you know yeah you get paid a
certain amount for that for that script
right
and then that script may never get made
I wrote a script for JLo for Jennifer
Lopez that I would like all the
Scotsman's has to get made it's for
Jennifer Lopez right no I did like 12
drafts on it
no got paid but that that movie will
never get made it's when you get a movie
made that's great that's a big deal but
yet the rest of the time you're you're
still working
you're still creating you're still you
know if you're lucky and you're getting
hired and and also you know then there's
the matter of coverage coverage is a big
deal and this in this business so
coverage is when the print you write a
script and the producer sends it to a
script reading company all right there
are several of them here in LA
and what they do is they have somebody
break read the script break it down and
then in the end there there's three
possibilities that they assign to it one
is pass this means no we're not
interested one is consider right which
is maybe if you know you work on it it
might might have potential and then the
Holy Grail recommend right now something
like 90% of the scripts that these
companies get get pass maybe you know
eight eight percent or so nine percent
get consider and there's variations of
considered as I consider with you know
considerations and so forth right but
it's still in the consider this is this
is pass this will consider one percent
of the scripts that that that go through
these companies get recommend so that's
what you're up against you know and you
know it when you get that if you if you
get that recommend that's a big deal
that's a huge deal
yeah what's the name of the check that
you get if if it actually principal yeah
because that's that's normally that's
when you'd get the money the rest of the
the big money or pet you would get for
for writing the screenplay yeah so a big
majority of what you do is writing
something doing many drafts getting paid
that initial chunk but most the time
something's not going to be it's not
going to go to production and yeah we'll
get through you know but keeping working
is you stay focused on it um luckily you
know sometimes those scripts are great
just because they don't get made it
doesn't mean they aren't good and you
can use them as as writing samples just
show that your yeah you know you're not
your snot you're not counting on it like
I I don't show anybody return The
Gargoyle anymore because it's dated and
it's from you know from early 90s or
whatever and and so I I can show them
something that I've written in the last
couple of years that is maybe it didn't
get made but it's still it's still too
real I think it's a terrific script or
someone else thinks it's a terrific
script and that will sometimes the the
person who's looking for a screenwriter
might read that and go oh I like I like
the attitude you had with this so yeah
we're gonna hire you you know and and
and in the invest case scenario is of
course your movie gets made but but yeah
I mean working screenwriters are not
putting out a movie you know every year
we might write three scripts Andy here
because it's really hard to get a movie
made it's really hard
anybody will tell you that in this
business it's tough and with I hate kids
there was already financing attached
right because Todd had his production
company uh well Todd found an investor
oh he okay a couple of them really but
we needed you need one to get you
started you need one you know that's
going to put in a good
chunk of that budget so that other
investors will go oh all right well
somebody else has put money into it what
happens all the time is you know a movie
starts to go into production and you've
got you've got a budget and you're but
you need some other investors and you
get somebody some people interested but
then your first investor drops out and
then that's that's a house of cards
that's just gonna gonna fall Todd and I
had a movie was a while back now another
comedy we had written that we were in we
were in pre-production we had to we had
the office open we were scouting
locations we were casting everything
like that everything was going
swimmingly and the investors had a
clause in their contract that said that
they could approve or disapprove the
three leads that killed us because they
wanted Reese Witherspoon and we tried to
explain to them you know Reese
Witherspoon gets you know we our budget
was like three and a half million
dollars right our recent this one gets
more than that for a comedy right alone
that's that's the whole budget right
there right I mean she might do like a
little art house kind of you know Oscar
potential role for for less money but
for a comedy no she's good that's our
whole budget right there so they oh they
want Anna Faris well Anna Faris is the
same deal you know and we struggled and
struggled and struggled to find
something they would approve if I
remember correctly Todd could tell me if
I'm remembering this right or not but I
so I recall read the script and liked it
it was ready to say yes and they they
said no to her oh really yes Wow so go
figure right so that room we ran out of
time to make that movie basically we had
to shut down and it's too bad because
that was a very very funny script I
still love to see that movie get made
yeah right I know
she's done a lot of great she's done a
lot of great stuff yeah yeah yeah I got
it so excited I was like oh that would
be awesome I would be super cool and
then a couple days later is like I
called it I call
the office the production office and the
guy was like now we're shutting down I
was like yeah so and I actually I
actually quit a job because because we
were in pre-production which goes to
show ya nothing nothing's in stone until
it is ya know
you